i mean there's so many circles and so
many like rabbit holes that
i'm sure people can fall down on youtube
that it's just like that we're just not
aware of
you know like it's because that just
shows how big youtube is as a platform
and
how like i mean i i feel for youtube
because when you have a platform this
big
no matter what you do there's going to
be something wrong with your platform
right
yeah 100 yeah but i i feel like what
they're doing with the dislike button is
it's going in the wrong direction just
because just because
a problem exists like removing your
ability to express it or removing your
ability to see that problem doesn't get
rid of the problem it just shifts it to
somewhere else
and yeah i i don't know i i don't know
what they were thinking i
don't know i feel it's not even about
like shifting it as well it's like it's
not only shifting it but i feel
more times than not it also propels it
into something like
a lot more toxic and a lot more just out
of control
i think it i think it would breed more
toxicity yeah because that just means
people have to find
another way it just means that like the
people who are shouting
the toxicity now just have to shout it
even louder yeah yeah yeah
like well i need people to see yeah i
have a problem with
yeah because if like part part of the
catharsis uh catharsism i don't know if
that's a word of like seeing a shitty
video
is just knowing that you're not the only
one who agrees that this is a shitty
video right exactly
right and you know there's there's you
know there it is it is good when you see
like this bad video this bad apology
and you know every you can see that one
the first thing you see
is the dislike button and the dislike
bar like my god
it was great seeing like youtube rewind
and just seeing that everyone
collectively agreed that it was just a
train wreck right
sorry youtube but it was i love how a
lot of the comments as well were like oh
man youtube was just salty that they got
there they got ratio
i don't think that was a reason on
record but it was funny it was a good
movie
but like this is the official reason
corporates at youtube are like
[ __ ] i can't believe people would hate
our products susan's just like i'm never
gonna forgive them like
i cannot believe it after all these
years she's just been planning this
for years waiting for like the right
person to be cancelled to be like
okay now it's the time to have an excuse
to implement
i wonder if they were like there was
just a youtube meeting they're like guys
everyone
everyone's hating on cancer culture
right now let's be the ones to end
cancer culture let's remove the dislike
button
and they're like oh my god you're a
genius they're gonna all youtubers are
gonna love this
who would have thought it was that easy
they can't be canceled anymore there's
no dislikes
why why is everyone hating this what is
happening i thought we were doing a good
thing i thought you guys hated cancer
removing negativity what that's what it
feels like
yeah it really is cause like like before
this i would say that actually i think
youtube was in a pretty healthy state
yeah twitter was [ __ ] but youtube was
good like yeah youtube was good
like twitter was like toxic and
obviously felt a bit vile sometimes but
youtube just felt like just a dislike
and that was it
it was just it was a nice balance it
wasn't like a little finger like
[ __ ] you yeah like [ __ ] you okay i'll
get on with my dick now
you know and like i think they have done
a lot of positive changes
um i do like the changes they did to the
copyright system it's not perfect
but it's better than it was before i
like the fact that you have to like
specifically put a timestamp of
what part is part of your videos being
copyrighted and as a creator you can
still remove that
you know part that's been copyright
strikes and have no effect on your
channel i think that's
like the best balance that we could have
hoped for and when you appeal for it it
like goes
the the money you make from that video
now goes into this limbo state where it
doesn't go to the creator and it doesn't
go to the supposed copyright holders
yeah that was that was a good chance
[ __ ] fantastic we've been wanting
that for years now and youtube was like
we've heard your feedback to be fair
that probably should have happened
in the beginning yes i mean it should
have happened in the
in the beginning but what i'm saying is
if they eventually did it yeah they
eventually did it and it felt like this
changed the changes they're making now
is just it's just unnecessary because
nobody asks for this and i think right
now
before this as a content creator i was
pretty happy with youtube as a platform
you know you knew what
you knew what you could get away with
you knew what you couldn't get away with
you know if
i i feel like right now if if a video if
one of your video gets demonetized aside
from aside from trash taste videos
because
yeah i don't know why half the videos
they got to monetize
yeah monetize most of the time if i
upload something and it's a 10 to 15
minutes
i know which videos are more high risk
to get demonetized and i know most of
the time
it's kind of on me for making that video
subject um
and then you have trash taste where for
some reason some of our podcast episodes
just get demonetized
and we hit and and it's just like we hit
we hit the appeal button and i
guarantee the person who's like
reviewing the content
did not watch the entire time like oh
[ __ ] it's two hours long
yeah jim you're gonna watch the whole
thing no [ __ ] it or just leave yellow
then
what's weird about the trash taste
episodes is that i think on record we
have about like maybe
five or six of the episodes now that are
still demonetized but it's five or six
episodes that
shouldn't have been demonetized yeah
like we look at it we look back at it
and we're like
i don't know what part of this video
flagged what but
we have like a bunch of other videos and
episodes where it's like
these are the ones if anything that
should have been demonetised
but they're not for some reason like the
combining episode that got demonetized
and yet the hentai episode is still
monetized
oh sorry the the fancy font episode
one is still monetized the greek letter
anyway oh my gosh yeah i don't know it's
just
i don't know the one time like one day i
think to myself
okay i figured out what exactly it is
that youtube does not like
yeah about whatever video it is that
flags their demonetization system and
then the next day i'm like
never mind i don't i don't know what you
want because another thing i've noticed
about youtube recently
is in in a positive light man when did
youtube comments
get really good i don't is that just me
what do you mean
what do you mean good the comment the
comment section right now like you click
on a random meme video and the comments
are always golden and i
it didn't used to be that way because it
used to be like this one overused joke
in every comment section but
no one connor yeah yeah yeah yeah like
the no one they were all [ __ ] copy
pastors yeah yeah
but not but not i don't know if it's
just me but i think like yeah pretty
funny
yeah like like half of my enjoyment when
clicking on a random video just go into
the comments section it's weird because
i feel like the whole like you know
commenting
on in a meme format in a meme video yeah
it's just like
i don't know people are just thinking to
themselves okay in order for me to stand
out in this absolute
cesspool of comments on this one video
yeah i actually need to be
surprised creative about it otherwise
i'm just going to get
swept in with all of these other like
meh so now people
now there's like this weird pressure to
be like if i'm gonna comment on this
meme video
i'm gonna make a [ __ ] bang a joke
otherwise
no one's gonna like it and it's just
gonna get buried and then you haven't
commented
in the first hour so you're not gonna be
in the top comments anyway yeah exactly